what's up y'all this is eric griffin and
big shout out today to helix sleep
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the mattress that
will give you the best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helixsleep.com
griffin yeah
rachel
you're so rude
let's start the show
all right ladies and gentlemen once
again welcome back to
your absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i was kind of jamming there for a second
i'm not even saying nothing
i really love my theme song yeah
shout out once again to doper pie and
everybody welcome back
welcome to
all right we're here back riffing with
griffin welcome back
once again i'm at the eric griffin uh
desk i'm at my
streaming desk you know she got a lot of
stuff going on i gotta go i'm actually i
got i booked this movie so i got a fly
to new york so i got all kinds of stuff
all over the place so i had to do my
podcast at my desk uh
so yep things are happening it's going
great so let's just get into it oh once
again you know i'm here every week
uh we're working with griffin and i
stream
most days i'm streaming on twitch at
eric griffin
gaming on twitch and then i put those
videos up on youtube eric griffin gaming
i actually streamed on youtube the other
day just to try it out if i haven't done
it in a while so
but you can see a lot of the videos i do
i put them up on youtube and i've got
some more
i'm getting my guy uh wiggy
he's gonna start doing some some videos
for the
the what do you call it for the gaming
too so i'll put more of that kind of
stuff up i'm just trying to do more
content i just got
i'm just getting real busy but before i
even go on even further guys i want to
give a shout out to um
this dude jj i don't want to say the
name wrong of the the watch brand but
it's
mono monoco monogon like genghis khan
i'm not even sure
so i'm just going to show you right
there you know it's jj
m-o-n-a-g-h-a-n i wish i knew how to
spell it properly say it properly but
you know
but there it is right there you know
really nice watch brand and he sent
rachel and i
his and hers watches
so let me open this up so you guys can
see so he sent
his and her watches for rachel and i you
know look at that pal
isn't her watches
pass i want to thank him uh it's good
stuff
i put them back in the box because it's
i like the boxes and they're nice
but it's uh you can find them on
instagram too just look up
m-o-n-a-g-h-a-n i guess i'll have it
right there
so you can see uh anyways so thanks man
thanks for the watches and i know he's
been like
what you need i need you to say
something about it you know he's been
real
like sending messages to rachel and
stuff like you know
celebrities ghost me it's like no man i
just been busy this is just you know
you you i have to do you it's you know
there's so much stuff to do and get
get through and i just do this and i
always forget so what i do is i put him
aside for myself to make sure
so i do one again thank him for that
shout out really nice watch brand so
make sure you guys check that out but
anyways you know i had a great week
you know i filmed the pilot bucktown you
know as you guys know i booked that show
bucktown
it's a abc pilot you know starring jane
lynch shannon woodward nicole richie
you know it's like um some other people
it's great
um so we filmed the pilot and i just
want to go go
you know tell you about it you know it
was crazy because like you know we
rehearsed all week you know you
rehearsed rehearsal rehearsal
rehearse you know and then you do run
throughs rehearsals run through so then
we had this like
run through on the day we were gonna
have
uh a live audience and the way they're
doing a live audience is they have to
actually pay the audience so it's like
as if it's part of the production so you
can have like 50 people in the audience
and it's you know because it's
it actually for a multi-cam you do need
the laughter you need a real audience it
is part of the production of the show so
it's not like it's not like you're like
gaming the system it's like it is
important for a multi-cam to have an
audience
so anyways so we had like 50 people in
the crowd but before that we had like a
run through we were going to record some
stuff have a run through
and and then so you know what's big
about these network shows is like the
network
is always watching and they have a
certain idea how they want the thing to
go so we do this run through
and then like i was a little nervous
because it was the first time i've seen
this it was like
all the cameras and everything was set
up and so i don't know if i
like like really nailed it but either
way
one of the producers of the show he like
pulls me is like he says hey man i want
to give you a pep talk you know
and it was nice we went on like a walk
on this you know we went on this nice
walk and he was really like
and i could tell it was like it was
important
you know he was like hey man like i need
you to do what you've been doing for
like
two three weeks now you know do that
because whatever was and i knew
i knew it i just i knew i needed it it
was
great um
you know i just sometimes you need that
you need like a kick in the ass
you know sometimes when things are so
important you overthink you know and i'm
thinking about everything
so i was overthinking i was like in my
head so he really grounded me and that
was great
so but even still though you know the
network is like
well we like i'm married to nicole
richie on the show
you know so we're like a couple and
we're the lead shannon woodward's boss
on the show but they're really a
stickler on like
we want to see their relationship you
know my
and nicole richie are we are they
married
so like literally an hour
before we're about to record in front of
a live audience the show
we get a new script from this scene that
i'm in
a new script y'all we've been rehearsing
for a week
and they hit you with like and it's like
a lot like mostly new lines so forget
the rehearsal on everything you've been
doing
so i mean i'm already was nervous so i'm
in the hallway like oh man
so not i'm just pacing around and i'm we
went over it a few times and they have
somebody there to help us so they'll
like you know read with you and then
we read with the main girl you know and
we just it just was
it was nerve-wracking but when we
finally sat down and we started doing it
it was
great i felt great the audience response
was good
everybody seemed to be happy and we
finished the show and it was just like a
good feeling and
you know people were like i haven't
hugged anybody in a year and i'm gonna
hug you right now it was just that kind
of feeling
so fingers crossed everybody it's gonna
be a while before we find out in terms
of riffing with griffin timeline you
know because next week i won't know by
next week
you know so as a as i get information
of course i'll let you guys know then
obviously if it doesn't get picked up
then boom then we're just back to the
drawing board and we're like you know
looking for work again so but it was fun
and that was uh that was that that's
what happened there so
um what are some things that i wanted to
talk about oh yeah so i got my
second coviz shot i did it
i did it today actually so i went
and it was like so when i first got it i
wasn't i guess
it was like one of these things where
you could get on like a list you know
and they have extras they don't want to
waste them so then they you know if
nobody comes then they're like they
reach out to their list
so i got on a list like that through
someone so like three or four weeks
it was like three weeks ago i got my
first shot so then like
but you're supposed to schedule your
second shot then so once you've already
got it you have to schedule the second
one
so there were there was no place to get
it at that time
it wasn't as readily available as it is
now i feel like it's
way more available so you know kudos to
biden or whoever is in charge of that
you know this ain't a political thing
i'm just saying
i'll i say biden because he made a point
of being like we want to make sure we
get this many viruses so that was like a
like a point of emphasis for him so if
if it was because of him
then great if it's because of someone
else whatever you want to believe i
don't
care i'm just saying thank you to
whoever that is
because now it's more readily available
but but it wasn't when i did it back
then
so then i had to schedule someplace and
it was like both of them were far away
so like the one the original one i did
was like 40 miles away from where i live
and then this one is like you know i had
to go and you know
30 minute drive again to get to get the
second one but you know i did it
and they said like there was more people
there getting it you could tell they
have a whole setup in the cvs
if you know you should go to cvs.com
actually go to cvs shout out to them
they make it real easy to sign up for
your thing you put your insurance
they just make it real easy so
and then you know i did the thing and
then the guy was like um
you know wait 15 minutes and see how you
feel because a lot of people have been
saying
on the second shot it's been taking them
out so that made me nervous
and the fact that i got to travel in a
couple days so i was like oh no
and then but the the production i'm
going to this this movie that i'm doing
you know they actually asked hey is has
he been vaccinated you know and i'm like
yeah well he's getting his second one
you know
so it's like i had to do it but at the
same time what if like tomorrow i'm like
i'm like you know so i mean i'm a little
like nervous about it right now but
i don't feel anything so far i mean i
got it in this arm and my arm is sore
but i'm not necessarily feeling any
symptoms so hopefully but i have so i've
been taking care of myself
i also take a lot of vitamin d my
vitamin d levels are high my b12
uh you know vitamin c so you know i try
to
like do those types of things to make
sure i'm healthy you know healthier
you know um so who knows we'll see you
guys will know
because if i get taken out i'll be you
know we'll talk about it next week but
as of right now it's been like all day
hours all day and i don't feel
you know i don't feel any
any kind of like symptoms or anything
like that so we'll see and then rachel
got her shot she got to johnson and
johnson
so she got the one shot and she didn't
feel anything either
like you know her arm was hurting but
she didn't have any like weird side
effects or anything like that so
right now i'm like you know like if a
titty grows on my forehead then you'll
know
uh oh something's up with the vaccines
[Laughter]
but you know it was cool um so i did
that so that's all
that's all said and done that's all out
there in the universe so here i am
you know i'm ready for open mouth
kissing so
you just come up to me and like are you
vaccinated yeah then tongue me
other people think it is but i'm ready
to go to this
i'm doing this movie in new york it's
pretty cool it's a ray romano movie he
like just directing starring
and uh producing the movie and i got
this little part i did like an audition
like
man this must have been like wait it was
even before the pilot audition i did
this audition
and i you know what shout out to my
buddy ben sieward who's been on the
podcast
because anytime i i need to do an
audition i do it with him like you know
over zoom you know so he'll be he'll be
my reader
you know and then we'll do the audition
but this is one of the i think this is
the first one
i think i've booked other things but
this is one of those ones where i calm
and go we did it man because it's like
you know that's the audition so people
like the audition
and you know he's a part of that so i
booked this one
so i called them and i was like yo man
we did it we finally booked one of these
jobs for these auditions we worked on
you know so he's like so i did help and
i was like well maybe
no he probably did he's great actually
he's great at it it's it's it makes it
easy i'm always thinking that somebody's
gonna hear him on and be like hey
who's that guy reading with you let me
let's get him in right
so and i'm all about that i've always
been about that i'm not like
one of these people that don't want
their friends to shine i ain't about
that at all
i'm all about that everybody should
shine life um
i have i even remember back in the day
i went to audition for this movie
and my best friend at the time jeff you
know he's still my best friend he's
still like we're still like super close
we're both trying to be actors this is
like 20 years ago it feels like
and i forgot the name of the movie but
anyway it was an open call for this
movie
right you know you didn't even need to
yeah
so i go to the audition and i go in and
then they immediately say to me the girl
goes hey
how old are you you know and i could
tell that i wasn't right for the part
but they let me audition anyway and i
could just tell
you know but i don't know you know what
i mean it was like one of those things
where they weren't sure and i was like
well i have a friend of mine right
and so i hit up jeff and i go yo dude
get
over here right now and audition for
this i think you'd be perfect
for this and he booked it he booked a
movie
so that's just one of those you know one
of those moments i want people to shine
you know
even saying that speaking of it's like
kudos to uh
steve and jeremiah you know there's i
believe they're starting their own
podcast
uh scissor brothers i think i was i saw
that
i think i was actually on that episode
of jeremiah wonders where
they were cutting each other's pubic
hair with scissors and now they're
calling themselves scissor brothers
i don't know if they've done that before
but either way is some weird [ __ ]
so they did their they they did their
april fools joke of doing
they call the good friends instead of
bad friends they did good friends
um so then now they're doing their
they've changed it to scissor brothers
so shout out to them so make sure you
check out their podcast
i don't i think it's i don't know if
it's audio and video or just video but i
don't know
i don't know if they have they're a
whole new thing or if it's still just on
jeremiah's thing or if they're going to
start their own channel and all that
kind of stuff i don't know but make sure
you look out for that you can find them
both on their things dbwb show
or jeremiah wonders so make sure you
check that out
um all right let's see what else is
going on so um
i watched oh man dude i got to tell you
guys
the falcon and the winter soldier is so
good episode 4 of that show was so good
shout out to sebastian stan he was on uh
dying up here he's such a good actor
like i
love what they're doing i just love it i
love how they're just really exploring
these characters and you're seeing like
another
side and it's always good when you don't
know who good
who the good guys are or who the bad
guys are so spoiler alert right now if
you haven't seen it
and at this point i don't care i'm
always worried about the spoilers but
this is spoiler alert city right now for
falcon and winter soldier so what i love
about what they're doing right now is
and this is always good storytelling and
you see this a lot right now is where
you don't know who
like there's no clear bad guy there's no
clear good guy
everybody's sort of gray area and you
have to kind of decide
who you want to root for or root against
so like the super soldier serum is out
there
and the people that have been displaced
displaced by
the blip you know the snap so thanos
hits the snap
people disappeared for five years now
they're back but the world
what happened like imagine you know what
are we supposed to do if people
disappear for five years
you know we're going to move on with our
lives things are going to change people
have lost their jobs they've lost their
money they lost their
belongings everything's gone and then
and then all of a sudden you know half
the population
billions of people come back so there's
like a whole thing that's going on in
this show about how
you know people aren't being helped and
people you know there's people that you
know so
these you know so the super soldier
serum has been stolen and now in
and then and these freedom fighters have
taken it so now they're you know you
have this person who's like
you think is the villain you know and
then like the falcon and the winter
soldier are like
trying to you know stop her from doing
the things that she's doing because
they're doing some revolutionary radical
stuff and then they break the
dude out of prison whatever his name is
vemmo or whatever he's the bad guy from
civil war and he's like a great
character you know
so like he's like helping them because
he has all the old-school hydra contacts
and so he's like he knows where to look
and but he but he's very clear
in his objective he wants to destroy
all super soldiers he thinks that there
shouldn't be god amongst men
he's just one of those people he you
know and he's adamant like he
kills the in the last episode he kills
the uh the scientists who
recreated the serum make sure that serum
can never be created
and then in this episode like the center
he he finds his serum and you think he's
going to take it and i thought that was
good because he picks it up and he looks
at it
then he slams it on the ground he starts
stomping all of them you know and then
like just like new captain america comes
and he like you know knocks him out now
let's talk about this guy this new
captain america okay
i like what they're doing because like i
say you don't know who the good guys are
the bad guys are
so this captain america is like bitter
that he don't have powers
right that's his thing he don't got
powers but my problem with this actor
and
now listen there ain't nothing on him
the dude's a great actor i like what
he's doing
but for me he got resting [ __ ] face
you know so at first
so i've never liked him but i like that
i didn't like him
you know he comes across like he's the
villain well it turns out
he he's become the villain you know
what was that movie that would they say
that you live long enough oh batman
you know you live you know you live long
enough to the hero becomes the villain
or whatever that saying was
so yeah so like so now you know this
captain america he gets some serum and
he takes it so now he's like now he's
like a real captain america now so
but he's a [ __ ] you know what i mean
but on purpose i know that they doing it
on purpose
i just wish that he was softer early on
so you can kind of root for him and be
like yeah this is going to be a good
captain america but the way they did it
it's like
you never like them you know especially
because you know we're following our
heroes we're following falcon and winter
soldier and bucky you know
we're following them and we like what
they're doing
you know we like sam and bucky you know
we like them so
and they're immediately and then there's
this whole thing about like why did sam
give up the shield you know captain
america
um steve rot steve rogers gave him
the shield you remember at the end of
avengers and so now
he didn't want to take up the mantle of
captain america and so he gave the
shield back to the government and the
government was like well [ __ ] we need a
captain america so they pick uh this
like you know
really like decorated soldier who by the
way and this is why i love what this
dude is doing as an actor like he's got
damage too like they had this great
scene about like you know
that one guy's telling him like yeah man
you're a hero you know you did this and
that he was like
he had this great point he was like yeah
they you know they give me medals
so they can i can be reminded of the
worst day of my life
because like well so whatever happened
on the battlefield was terrible like his
people died you know what i mean like
it's like so
great how they're delving into like each
person's psyche i love that so he's a
little bitter
he's like yo man you know if i was a
super soldier that
that day that my people died it would be
different
right so he has this and you already
know he's gonna take it
like i didn't even need like there was
no doubt that he was going to take that
stuff
you know he needed to take it because so
he could be like a real captain america
but then like the bad guys and i don't
even know if they're bad guys really now
that's what i
i love the gray area in that
you know they accidentally kill his
partner and then he goes buckwild
berserk and that's how they ended the
episode
but everything leading up to that was
great you know sam's trying to talk her
down
you know it's like and then oh and then
the chicks from wakanda come
you know because they remember the the
the bad guy from civil war
she ended up making the winter soldier
kill the king of wakanda
so now these are like the personal guard
you know ball head badass
chicks right that's my only problem
though and this is
i always talk about this the weird power
levels if you're a super soldier
like sam falcon he don't got no powers
other than
he got this you know flying thing but
he's not
super strong the fact that he can hang
with the super soldiers when they fight
is ridiculous to me okay so i don't get
i don't get that
so then like these women come and they
beat captain america's
ass that
to me what was funny is you know what
made captain america
take the super serum when he was like
when the black women beat him up
that's that was his that was that that
was the inciting incident for him to be
like
you know what i got to take this super
serum so i could be
stronger guy because these bald head
black women
beat my ass so
that's what made him take the uh the
serum and he even says that they didn't
even they weren't even super soldiers
and they because they just demolished
him
so you got these people are here because
they're like yo we want this dude to
kill our
killed our king because they're like
this they're like the
um secret service of wakanda and the
king got killed on their watch
so they're like yo we're shamed and then
they
also have a relationship with bucky the
winter soldier because they when he was
living on wakanda
she helped him um you know
remove that brainwashing stuff from his
head so she helped him and that was a
great scene
he's all crying and you're like oh man i
feel bad for this assassin you know
and so they help him
you know they helped him you know so
they have this great relationship but
she's like oh i give you eight hours
he's like look we need this guy he's
helping us and so
you know but that's gonna all come to a
head and of course that guy escapes
you know what i mean and then like you
know they i love how they always ended
at a good cliffhanger so
this episode four was so good like i
really hope
they keep this going like i hope it's
not like one season like
wanda and one division oh
please i hope that they keep this falcon
and winter soldier going like
it was completely worth the wait i was
so mad when disney plus first came out
and then like a year went by we had one
season of mandalorian and then
nothing else so we just got finished
having like the mandalorian
second season and then they did one
division and now they have falcon winter
soldiers so it's like you got to keep
it coming man like if you want to
compete with netflix that's how you got
to do it you got to be like boom boom
boom boom boom
keep putting stuff out so hopefully
hopefully they uh continue with the
falcon and
the winter soldier they go like at least
like two or three seasons would be great
two solid seasons uh if you give me two
solid seasons with like
movie arcs i would i would love that
that would
be awesome boom
all right so what else is happening um i
didn't want to talk about something but
we should talk about it really
delicately so let me let me just look it
up
you know so there was this uh draymond
draymond green the basketball player you
know he had he was in the news
talking about
let's see that he was talking about the
pay gap between
men and women you know
and he he got into it with
you know one of these with megan rappino
i think she's like on the u.s soccer
team
for the women's u.s soccer team so let's
see uh
topic of the day national team mega
rapino ripped
his remarks saying it's unfortunate that
an athlete in green's position didn't
have
have a more informed opinion
um but i'm trying to see what was his
initial
opinion that's what i that's what i'd
like to see
um you know i don't know i'm doing this
like like live on the spot here
yeah i agree he had some kind of tweet
and i think he tweeted something and
then like you know
but anyways you know
i think there is there is obviously a
paid discrepancy but
but there is something to be said about
like the nba
versus the wnba you know because then
because then i heard
i was watching a sports show and there
were some xw nba players who were now
sports commentators and they were
talking about you know support to wnba
and
you know buy jerseys and all this kind
of stuff and i have
my only listen first of all let's frame
the conversation like this
just because if i take the position like
i am not a fan of the wnba it doesn't
mean i hate women
like let's not let's not go there you
know like
in the same way that if like someone
white has a criticism of something that
say
is predominantly black but they have a
certain criticism of it and it has
nothing to do with race like not
everything has to do with race and
gender not everything has to do with
that
i understand that that is an important
thing that's happening right now you
know that you know it is important
that's why i'm trying to say this i'm
trying to talk about it delicately but
i like talking about things i like you
know i'm not afraid to like go go in
um go in you know so
like i say so what i'm about to talk
about right now please don't
have ill intent don't think that i have
any kind of ill intent
i really don't i i'm very supportive of
females women however you supposed to
say it you know
like you get in trouble for how you even
say things you know people but don't put
words in my mouth or don't put words in
my intent i'm telling you right now
i'm super supportive of of this like i'm
like this show bucktown is like
there's so many women working on this
project it's crazy like
three of the producers the director the
executive producer the
the writer the the camera operators the
first ad
it was all women you know uh the cast is
it's all women you know so
it's it's um you know i'm fully
supportive of that but
you should be able to have a discussion
about these types of things without it
turning into like
you know some kind of hate-mongering or
whatever people are going to say it's
that's not what it is
but just strictly when it comes to the
and i've talked about this before
i'm not a fan of the wnba not because
it's women
it's because it's not great it's not nba
basketball
look the fact that the nba exists we
can't get that out of our head
basketball is the kind of sport that
lends itself
to accentuating athleticism so
the strongest fastest highest jumping
most
athletic person is is um
going to shine in basketball and that's
what we like to see
yeah there are other types of players
but we always say about them
oh they're scrappy they're smart because
they don't have
the athleticism you look at a guy like
blake griffin
who because of injury injuries his
athleticism went away
it went it was not as as good as it was
before
he's not the same player because of that
that's what the nba does that's what nba
that's with basketball
it's a very challenging taxing sport and
the most
athletic people are the ones that shine
lebron james when
because we see lebron james a dude who's
six seven with three percent body fat
fast and can dribble and jump out of the
gym that's what we like
so when you have that in the nba
you look at the wnba in comparison it
don't even look like the same sport so i
don't like it
and even in the nba i don't even watch
all the nba teams
because i don't like you know i don't
like college basketball the way some
people like cosplay for that same reason
i like basketball at the highest level
and that
is the nba you know and there are even
teams in the nba i don't even look at
because i'm like they sorry
you know what i mean you look at the
college basketball they only show
they show mostly division one on tv why
because it's at the highest level of
college basketball
they don't show division three
basketball on tv it's not on ab you're
not gonna see on cbs oh the division
three basketball because
this they're not as good as the highest
level division one
and these guys aren't as good as the nba
so it's like the nba is the highest
level so
when you look at that you go and that's
the reason why i think
that wnba isn't supported as much as
as they want it to be you know i think
the nba is doing a great job of like
trying to jam it down our throat and and
like keeping it afloat because i'm
i from all reports it's not making any
money
from all reports so when you talk about
the paid discrepancy in the nba
there i have a problem with that between
nba and because the wnba is not bringing
in the same money that the nba is
bringing in
and the nba is fully supporting the wnba
by having these teams and paying these
salaries that they have and
whatever money comes in from whatever
support but it's not the same kind of
support as the nba
it's not it's not looked at the same
they don't have the same ratings it
don't
you know and i'm just telling you i
don't like it so i don't watch
but i don't even like all of the mba
this is just me i'm just speaking for me
like i say i don't watch every nba game
i'm not a purist like oh i just love
watching basketball
that's not what i'm into so you know i'm
i like the best players doing best
player stuff
so when you watch you know the wnba and
these and
hey these women are great talented
basketball players you know they're
obviously they're tall they're
they're fast for what they do but it
ain't the nba
you get what i'm saying so i think
that's why and i think a lot of people
feel that way but it always gets framed
in like you know sexism and you don't
like women or it always gets framed when
it's men versus women
and to me it's not about that to me it's
about
this is the basketball at its highest
level and what it looks like now
that being said other sports it's not
the same
like women's tennis i like women's
tennis way better than men's tennis
i think that's where super athleticism
counts against you
the strength with it's just all sir hard
serves i think the women's tennis
is a way and men's tennis and women's
tennis
they look the same so when you're
watching them on tv
even if the men are a little bit more
athletic a little faster it's still when
you're watching them side by side
you don't see the big difference when
you watch an nba game
you're like you know they're zipping up
and down the court they're
jumping and dunking and all the things
that they're doing when you watch an mw
nba game
it don't feel the same it's not as
exciting
because of the lack of what the men's
basketball has
but in tennis you don't have that and
that's why
tennis women's tennis players get paid
so much money they get paid a lot of
money
and they're probably still i know that
there's still a pay gap there's still a
but
in a sport like tennis i'm with you 100
percent what are we doing
we should find ways to like level the
playing field and support women more
in those type of sports i'm a women's
volleyball fan
i love women's volleyball i wish there
was a pro women's volleyball league
i would love that if they had like i
don't know if you ever watched women's
volleyball it is
so exciting it's like a slam dunk every
single play
the bump set spike the the intensity of
volleyball
i love volleyball so that's just me so
when i see men's
i like men's volleyball like women's
volleyball but they look
very similar the things that happen is
very similar
looking there isn't like a huge visual
your eye test a visual discrepancy so
you know you have sports like golf and
like even soccer i like
women's soccer too it looks it's it's
you know you can enjoy that
hockey is one of those sports too that
even though hockey's just
in a super engaging sport it really is a
great sport to watch live at any level
there's something about it it's so fluid
and and
interesting to watch that i even think
that the women's hockey but i don't even
know if there are a lot of women's
hockey teams i don't even know if
there's like a
there's no women's pro hockey league
right see i don't even know and if there
is they're not doing a great job
publicizing it so in terms of these
other sports other than the nba
i think that you know we we do need to
do better
we do need to do better to make sure
to help promote female sports
women's sports women and the athletes
make them
you know publicize them you know
but you know i i don't know i mean
they're
i mean we we are i mean that look we
just got to face it we still are very
much a sexist country
we are you know we it's going just just
as long as it
for the same amount of time it takes to
like weed out racism in our country
weed out prejudice and all this it's you
know women are still dealing with that
same thing so
you know it's tough too because like as
a comic i love talking about women on
stage you guys are hilarious and you're
also
50 of the population it's not like there
are like
you know however many species
like if i was talking about animals and
but i singled out horses
and all i did was talk about horses
horses could be like yo man
what about the ducks what about the
geese
why don't you talk about the ants why
are you just talking about me
if if that were the case you're right
then it does
feel like uh i got a problem with horses
because with all the animals i can
choose from i keep picking the horses
yo there's two there's men there's women
and of course now okay you ha you could
now there's subcategories of that too
it's you know
it's either men that are saying they're
women or women who are saying we're men
or
or or people that are like well we're
nothing where we're none of those things
where
whatever okay
[Laughter]
you know
you know what i mean as a comic when
you're talking about that it's not like
there's a lot of choices
you know so it ain't about hating women
you're you're
you know 49 of the population so if men
are 49 women are 49
and that other 2 percent or all the
people will lump all those other people
into that
other category that they want to be
whatever they are you know non-binary
and all that stuff
okay great but forty-nine percent of the
population
yeah as a comic i'm i
it's so it's okay that i talk about that
too
it's just how you talk about it i guess
you know but like i say there's always
going to be a butt of a joke
sometimes the butt gets slapped so yeah
i just thought that that was interesting
um you know discussion about what's
happening
in terms of the pay discrepancy and what
they're trying to do but it's like you
know you just have to like
you know it's about money it's about
generating money not about
worth it's not about like do the female
the
the women's athletes they do the same
thing that the men's athletes do
okay but they're the eyeballs on the
sport that generate
ad revenue it's not the same so
therefore there's a pay discrepancy
you know but i feel like in those sports
that
like i said that it looks equivalent
like tennis for instance we they should
but those
but those those are the ones that make a
lot of money you know
so i don't know it's a nuanced
discussion and hopefully
hopefully we're just gonna continue to
get better right race relations
uh you know gender relations
hopefully we'll just continue to move
forward and get better at it but
in the meantime there's gonna be these
like little flare-ups and things and if
all we have to do is just have
just frank honest common sense
discussions you know
don't assume what the other person is
thinking and saying and feeling
even if it makes you feel a certain way
i mean i think that everybody when they
say stuff they should add the words to
me
you have to add the words to me it's
like you don't say
to someone like oh i listen to your
podcast and you
hate women okay to
you because when you say to me
then i don't it's like okay that's just
your perception
if people put out their nonsense you
know
so it is important that we frame these
discussions correctly and
understand that people are sensitive to
certain things it's like if it's
sensitive and
you might have a point to make you know
you might even have a point to be like
well when we talk about these kinds of
things it makes people think a b and c
well then that's us discussing it too
then let's let's get that out there
so then if people hear us talking about
it then
you know if you know you if you hear
two people from opposite viewpoint
actually having a frank discussion an
honest open discussion about something
it might help you either strengthen your
point
or understand the other side better i
mean that's just what we're missing
that's what debates and stuff are
supposed to be for
debating is supposed to be like to like
get all the information from both sides
and then you make an
informed choice so i don't know
hopefully we'll get there
hopefully we'll get there all right guys
um i'm not i usually cut away from these
kinds of things but i thought you know
let's not cut away i just want to talk
to you guys once again about helix sleep
our great sponsor
for the show um healy sleep i have one
best mattress you'll ever have i
guarantee that for you guys
helix sleep are you having trouble
sleeping you know with everything that's
going on in the world with the pandemic
with
with the job with you know getting the
vaccine you're not sure
uh healing sleep is the place man you
don't have to go to some crazy store
anymore and lay down in a mattress to
figure out if it's good
they have this great thing they have a
sleep quiz helix sleep has a quiz that
takes two minutes to complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you
i mean it's really great when you think
about the questions that they have on it
are you a side sleeper you know and they
and and you know i took the quiz and i
got one because i'm a side sleeper it's
soft it's great
i love it i always feel good but you
need to know
uh is it because it's like do you want a
soft medium a firm mattress do you sleep
on your side your back your stomach do
you move a lot at night they ask you all
these questions and they fix a mattress
right
for you all right so this is really
important all right um so if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress
it's matched to you the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for
free you never need to go inside the
mattress store again like i said
now the thing you got to do guys is just
go to helixsleep.com
griffin take the two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to that custom
mattress like i said
they have a 10-year warranty and if you
if you get to try it out for a hundred
nights you get to try it out for a
hundred nights if you don't like it
they'll take it from you for free
they'll even pick it up you know if but
i'm pretty sure you're gonna love it i'm
telling you you will
you're gonna love this mattress helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
griffin you hear me healingsleep.com
griffin check that out
i guarantee you'll have the best sleep
of your
life all right guys let's uh we're going
to end the show with
one of my favorite segments to do it's
real world advice
from a grown ass man
that's what i'm going as man i got these
glasses but they don't have the right
prescription in them so i have to like
but
they're good for like driving but like
they don't have the i'm like an old ass
man where i have to have the
the by the bifocal area so like so i can
look down and read so these don't have
that
all right all right here's our questions
for today for real world advice from a
grown-ass man
i know both matter but what's most
important morals or money
you know i don't like when people frame
things like this they don't
both matter morals and money can matter
but if you're saying you had to choose
between the two
i mean obviously to be a good person it
would be morals
but there's a moral way to make money
you know what i mean
and and if you don't if you're not
taking care of yourself and your family
by making money maybe that's immoral you
know what i mean maybe are you being
moral
if you're not taking care of business to
take care of your family to make to make
the money you need i mean you know what
i mean so
my answer to this question is like don't
frame everything like that it doesn't
have to be
like one versus the other in in these
kind of things so i almost sort of
reject the question but you know you
could be a moral
person and you could be somebody that is
trying to be compensated for the work
that they do
you know so good luck man some of these
questions i get to
i don't even know if the people
sometimes it's just a lot of joke
questions so
i try to determine if i pick the ones
that are like the
the real questions you know all right
how do i hold conversations on race with
my white friends
who grew up in a bubble well that's a
lot
you know i don't know your whole
situation but i get to the gist of this
question is
you know the thing is it's like again
this is like what we were talking about
earlier when i was talking about the
the the athletes you know you just got
to find a way to have
like a a gray area nuanced
discussion about things if this is
something you really want to talk about
with your friends
because they're white and you feel like
because they're white they have some
sort of
feeling towards you or towards race and
that's what's inspiring you to bring
this up
okay then then talk to them about that
if they're your friends you should be
able to have like an open discussion
like hey guys i'm feeling this way and
then
but don't make it all about you make it
about them too like
hey what do you guys feel about this
are you do you go am i you know cause
you then you can like
find out where people are coming from
like like and every not everything has
to be framed in race gender and sexual
orientation either i just i
i hate that we live in a world like that
you know because you also
don't want to be the woke person all the
time man
you don't want to be the wokest person
in a room all the time
like oh that's just infuriating man
it's like forever for any on any level
you don't want to be about race
you don't want to be the person that's
always like well you know black people
black people haven't been able to do
such it's like if you're that person
that has to bring that up
all the time that's great all right and
i'm not saying not be that guy
fight the power okay but also know
that not everybody's gonna want to be
around that all the time but that's just
that's the the cross you bear same thing
with women
guys if everything's feminism
if if it's always framed that everything
we're doing everywhere we are
we have to always worry about like
you're going to be that person that's
like oh hell you know good morning well
not for women
you know if you're going to be one of
those people don't be surprised if
people don't want to hang out with you
sometimes sometimes
i mean my analogy for this is like
you had a bar with your friends you know
it's a party
everybody goes to the bar and they're
about to order drinks for the group
and then somebody says oh you know bob's
here
you know danny's here you know what i
mean danny's here and you know danny's
you know he's in the program and he's
recovering so can we just all have
ginger rails
for danny all right everybody looks at
each other and they're like okay
this our boy danny let's do it you know
everybody get to ginger ale and
you have a great night and nobody gets
drunk and and everybody feels
comfortable
but the next time you go out
they're like yo we gonna go to that bar
again some people might be like
uh is danny coming because
i want to get my drink on tonight
that's fair that's that's a
fair feeling okay that's how it is to be
around
somebody who's woke all the time 24
hours a day they woke
bye don't want to be sometimes i don't
want to deal with that
you know it's like if you're with
somebody it's just like
oh man i've done like comedy shows man
doing a comedy show and you're talking
to somebody hey who's on the show and
there'll be that one person
you say the lineup oh wow man women
whatever somebody's like
oh well this is all white you're like
okay
i'm out you know what i mean it's like
if you want to like
nitpick all the time that's great
like i said fight the power more power
to you
but remember there will be times when
people
just don't want to deal with that so
that's just like i said that's just the
cross you beer but anyways
and that's in terms of this too don't be
that guy
you know there's a time and place to
bring that kind of stuff up but these
are also still your friends
whether they're white or not but if you
have a problem
with your white friends that's on you
and if they're and if you have friends
that you feel like oh they don't really
understand
well you either gonna take it as this is
your job
to school your white friends in your
life and culture
if you want to be that guy make sure you
know
make sure it's worth it you know what i
mean make sure you're doing it also just
for yourself too
do it for yourself and you're doing it
because you want your friends to like
know how they sound i mean sometimes
that's
why we do things too you know you have
somebody a loved one in your life and
they might have enough they might say
something when you go ooh
hey you know if i don't want
people to hear you say that because
they're going to think bad of you
because it sounds like this
you're trying to explain to them that
way you're like yo you know someone
might miss
misconstrue what you're saying so let me
let me
school you on this real quick so that
doesn't happen to you
and then that person might be like oh i
didn't know that or you know you know
what i mean but
however you bring up the discussion you
know just be delicate
because you just don't want to be that
guy that's always
woke 24 hours a day like ugh
not for me son not for me but good luck
homie all right so what was that one
um okay boom let's keep going
um i need that motivation to work on my
craft
i get caught up with life and i get
discouraged i answered this one on
instagram too and i want to do it again
here it's like look
i don't think the guy's discouraged then
the guy is distracted
you know when when you know they're
i don't believe in the concept of
there's not enough time
i i'm a believer that you always make
time for the things that are important
to you
and how do you make time for things that
are important to you you have to be
organized you got to schedule
so i'm telling you like you know that's
what use your iphone
i'm you know what rate man rachel is
great at this like she
if she has to go to work she has like
five different alarms that go off on her
phone
it's annoying because i'm there
sometimes i'm sleeping
but it's like she goes oh that's my
alarm to get up
that's my alarm that i need to be
dressed by this time oh that's my alarm
if i want to eat i got to do it now and
this is my mom that i got to get in the
car i got to you know so she organizes
herself that way
if you're somebody that gets distracted
if you're somebody that you know you're
this person that i can't get stuff done
use your phone man use these apps that
they have you know
set calendar reminders and say yourself
all right i'm going to work on my thing
from this time to this time i'm going to
do this from this time this time
you know you start looking at your life
and you might be like oh well maybe i'm
watching too much tv
while i'm instead of watching tv i could
be doing this or instead of playing
video games i could be doing that
you know so just get your life in gear
that way
just schedule and organize and you won't
be discouraged because you're only
discouraged because
in your mind when you're discouraged
it's because you want to be doing
something else
but you are in charge of that it's your
choice
you know what i'm saying just ain't
government assigned you're choosing the
things that you want to do
so i believe that you'll be able to make
time for the things that are important
to you and so
you know just do that my friend all
right
good luck all right here's one
super toxic relationship stay
or leave fighting almost every day
i mean leave you know what i mean
like i don't know why we we stay in
these toxic relationships i think
because we're so insecure
sometimes you get into a relationship
and it it goes good
and you start to think well this is as
good as it's gonna get i'm never going
to be with anyone else so i have to make
this one work
or you have some sense of loyalty that
you have it's like well
i i don't want to be the reason you know
that this didn't work so i want to put
all my efforts to make it work but
listen
if you're using the if you're using
words like
toxic
you know so the only effort you should
be trying to make is like addressing
that
hey i feel like we have a toxic
relationship
for these reasons a b and c and i would
like us to work
on this so we can move forward
positively
and if that person can't get on board
with you with that
then you have your answer and you have
to like
hold your head up high and know that
there is better
out there for you there's better for you
you can treat yourself better
so go out there and treat yourself
better by working on yourself
and then getting yourself away from
anybody that you consider
is it has a toxicity to them that
because that is just that kind of
negative energy you don't want to be
around
but if you care about this person and
you and there is you see a light you see
i know i
i want to make this work then you have
to make the effort to make it work by
addressing this stuff letting it fester
and all that
that's on you too because then you're
just going to come to a head and it's
just
not going to end well so communicate my
friend
communicate all right
that was a good one i had to lift my
glasses up i'm so sorry i feel old
33 year old single father with two girls
looking to date got any tips or tricks
okay listen i don't have kids i've never
had kids but i've seen this situation
um listen man you just have more to
think about you know
and what did he say he was a single
father too you have a lot to think about
so whoever you bring into your life you
need to you know that
your kids are your priority
so you can make time too like i said to
the other guy
schedule your time out when it's date
time and i don't know when you drop this
on who whoever you're dating or
how long you talk to someone before you
go on a date or you know are you
chatting online first for a while are
you revealing information
you know early are you like yo i'm a
single father with two kids so
you know i i can only go out from this
time to this time i mean are you
revealing that stuff early i don't know
what your
your thing is but you have time to do it
and
you have to make that choice so it's
like when you get to know someone
i do highly suggest like if you're
dating apps to be like hey let's get on
facetime and
you know try to talk to the person get
to know get a vibe get a feel talk about
kids talk about that kind of stuff so
you know because you're not gonna just
bring some rando near your kids
if you're trying to date now if you're
just trying to smash
you are i'm sure you already know how to
do that that's a completely different
set of it's completely different set of
rules and energy that you're trying to
because that you could keep that away
from your kids all right but if you're
trying to date you're trying to get
serious with someone
they how they feel about that person is
important so you need to make sure you
cross in all your
you know check boxes with this person
you know that they're going to be
that they're going to be someone that
you would want to have
near your children so good luck with
that man
all right see we're almost done here uh
this one i thought was funny i don't
even know if it's real or not but he
said
how do you pretend to like people you
really want to beat them down with a bat
well i mean that's just like that's just
it is what it is that's just about
brushing [ __ ] off your shoulders man
not letting people get to you like you
know we have work
people that at our work we don't like
but we have to deal with
and that's all that is you know you
don't have to you don't have to pretend
to like people
but it's okay to be cordial and nice
it's okay to be like
you don't have to be standoffish it's
okay to say good morning
that's all you don't have to have a
relationship with everyone in your life
everyone you meet you do not have to
like exchange birthday cards with them
you don't have to pretend at all you
could just you could
indifference is what you need man you
know how many people you cross
people's path all the time and you don't
have to you know
do anything more than you do now if it's
someone like a father-in-law a
mother-in-law
you know a sister-in-law or like you
know you're your girl's best friend
and you just don't like her i mean there
is still a way to
those are things you have to try to
address but just in general
you don't have to be buddy buddy with
every single person you meet
you know so just you don't got to be
standoffish either you know what i mean
it's a fine line you got to find the mix
you know find the mix but good luck
here's one i want to be a firefighter
but i'm 32 and i'm afraid i'm too old
well i mean you won't know you're too
old until you go try
you know if you go there and you go hey
i want to be a firefighter and they go
get your old ass out of here you're 32.
then you know you can't do it
but if you're in great shape and this is
your calling and you always wanted to do
this
i say go for it go do it go to fire
school
because they'll let you know you know
like what are you afraid of
if you think you could do it go try it
and that just goes for all of you for
anything that you want to do go do it
just go do it let them tell you you
can't do it but don't let it
be you thinking you can't do it for some
arbitrary reason
for some like unknown thing that you
don't really know the answer to
so don't answer for other people don't
don't put words in the fire department's
mouth
you go hey where do you sign up and
they'll be like oh great
it don't mean that you have to you know
and 32 is not old man
and maybe you if you just i don't know
you want to fight fires
go try it out all right get out of your
head
um last one this one's weird like i said
i don't even know if this is real or not
but someone said should i ask a girl
even though i think she's a lesbian like
i guess
should i ask a girl out i mean again
how do you know i mean if if it's
a woman who is
already professed hey i'm lesbian and if
she's dating someone
then you don't what are you trying to do
but if it's just some girl you know
and she says hey i'm a lesbian and you
want to go
to her and be like are you sure are you
trying to confirm it like i don't know
what you're trying to do do you really
is it someone you hang out with
regularly and you go well i really i'm
attracted to this person
all you have to do is just ask you just
go hey i'd like to take you out
you know i really i'm into you you know
and if she goes oh well
you're barking up the wrong tree i'm
just not into you at all like that
i'm this then you have your answer but
if you go to her and you go and she's
like oh that's cool because i've
actually dated men in the past or
or i'm bisexual or whatever they want to
say her thing is you never know
stop speaking for people just go do it
go try i don't know why we don't do this
more i don't know why people don't just
just
go whatever you want go try to get it
go get your answers you know that's
really what i'm trying to say is
go get the answer
go find out hey
what's up you want to go out cause i'm
into you
then that per you put it on them then
they're going to be like yes
no and this is why and then you go oh
cool
i tried it out move on all right all
right guys
um that's going to be our episode this
week uh riffin with griffin
i want to thank our sponsor helix sleep
love them
um so make sure you you know go go take
their sleep quiz
and once again i want to thank my man
for sending me these his and her watches
so check him out on instagram jj
m-o-n-a-g-h-a-n
um you know and uh stay fresh guys
i'm gonna be if i if i actually if
everything goes through and i'm gonna go
doing this movie i'll be in new york for
a couple of weeks so i'll be doing my
podcast out there
uh from my hotel room you know in
between shooting and stuff so hopefully
i'll
let me see if i can hit up some some of
my peeps out there in new york
get somebody on the podcast yeah so i
got to bring my mic
be able to you know i got to bring all
my stuff and see what i can get done
but thanks for being here thanks for
listening
check me out on eric griffin gaming
twitch youtube
and you know just keep being you guys
and we'll just keep doing this and look
out for my patreon content
i got i went i i recorded myself going
to get my
vaccine shot so i'll put that
video up and rachel and i are gonna do
some more videos and stuff but yeah
i don't know i'm just out here doing it
man i'm chill i'm relaxed
and please keep your fingers crossed
that my show gets picked up
uh man just keep keep that good energy
out there for me too and
thanks for watching we're from griffin
and i'll see you next week
you